♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute, and I'll show you
how Virtual Private Cloud
serves as a foundation
for your network in the cloud.
Virtual Private Cloud, or VPC,
is the managed networking service
for your Google Cloud infrastructure.
You could think of it as similar
to a traditional physical network,
except it's virtualized
within Google Cloud.
VPCs on Google Cloud have a global scope,
so a single VPC can span
across multiple regions
all over the world, securely,
without communicating
across the public internet.
VPCs are shareable between
Google Cloud projects
or even organizations in some cases.
That means you can use
a single shared VPC
for your entire organization
so that teams isolated within projects
can maintain a shared private IP space
to access commonly used services.
Need to expand your network?
No problem.
Google Cloud VPC lets you increase
the IP space of any subnet
without any downtime or workload shutdown,
giving you the flexibility to grow
your network to meet your needs.
By default, your Google Cloud projects
are ready to roll with a default VPC
configured with multiple subnets
created across multiple regions.
You can use these subnets
or you can create your own,
allowing you to configure
the number of subnets,
their corresponding regions,
and their IP address ranges.
Do you have existing infrastructure
outside of Google Cloud
that you want to connect to your VPC?
There are multiple ways to create
a hybrid-networking solution
using Dedicated or Partner Interconnect,
Cloud VPN,
or even via partner-supported
SD-WAN connections.
Keep things on your network safe
and secure with Packet Mirroring.
This allows you to mirror all traffic
between your compute instances in your VPC
so that you can inspect and analyze it
for application performance issues
or to detect threats and anomalies.
So, next time you're looking into
how you can build
your network in the cloud,
take a minute to check out
Google Cloud VPCs
or Private Managed Network in the cloud.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/vpc